Welcome students to the
pharmacology of drugs
used for coagulation
disorders and in this
part one we'll be
describing the pharmacology
of the anticoagulants.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Here are the learning
objectives. Pharmacokinetics is
important to understand with
these drugs for optimization
of therapy, potential drug
interactions etc these
structure activity relationships
will help understand
help students understand
the mechanisms of these
drugs and you need to know
the clinical uh the clinical
uses and you need to know
the mechanisms of adverse
effects drug interactions
and how all these relate to
the contraindications the
adverse effects interactions
relate to the complications
sorry contraindications
for the use of the specific
drugs preparation materials
and here are some links
and key concepts which I'm
not going to read to you
however I want to emphasize
strongly that understanding
platelet activation the
coagulation cascade
amplification of throbin and the
fibrinolytic process are
essential for understanding
the pharmacology here are
some terms that I'll be using
in this lecture the key
points are organized according
to the drugs, drug classes.
So we have heparin,
unfractionated heparin, low
molecular weight heparin,
fondoparinox,
the direct acting oral
anticoagulants, which are factor
XA inhibitors, and one
direct acting thrombin
inhibitor, and the parenteral
direct thrombin inhibitors.
And finally,
warfarin, which is the only
vitamin K antagonist that's
used in the United States
at the present time. I'm
going to take a very brief
overview of coagulation,
platelet activation. I
strongly recommend watching
a YouTube video. Some of
them are quite good. I
put a link here for the
Khan Academy video, which is
very clearly, very clearly
describes the process.
Hemostasis is important for
stopping blood loss from
a damaged vessel the
involved factors are platelet
adhesion platelet activation
platelet aggregation
coagulation factors
generation of a fibrin clot
that's going to hold that
platelet plug in place stabilize
it and then that's
followed by wound healing
and reversal of the coagulation
platelet aggregation
effects let's start with
the initial injury the wall
defect and the platelet the
activated it will activate
the platelet which will
stick to the wall and that
will cause granulation of
various products in in the
granules so So we see adenosine
diphosphate, thromboxane,
A2, and serotonin, and
these will go on to activate
other platelet factors
which will release the
contents of their granules
which will just enhance, augment
the whole process. so
platelets stick together
stick to each other put a
plug in that that wall defect
act and the coagulation
cascade gets activated along
the way and that produces
fibrin so we have our
antiplatelet drugs our
fibrinolytics and our anticoagulants
looking at the coagulation
cascade this is as simple
as I can explain it there are
two pathways traditionally
called the extrinsic and
intrinsic pathways the
extrinsic pathway is also
known as the tissue factor
activation pathway because
the endothelial wall injury
will cause a release of
tissue factor so tissue
factor is activated the
intrinsic pathway is called the
surface activation surface
contact activation pathway
we'll talk about the tissue
act factor activation
pathway first this is a
major reason for the for
instigating the whole process
so we have the endothelial
damage with the expression
of tissue factor, and that
combines with 7a, and that
will form a complex with
calcium. It's called 10a's,
10a's, or extrinsic 10a's,
and so a's, meaning it's
now protease that's going
to convert factor 10 to
factor 10a and it will also
convert factor 11 to factor
sorry that's 9 factor 9 to
factor 9a so 10 and 9 and
then the extrinsic pathway
converges with the
common pathway so now the
surface active surface
contact activation pathway
is because it gets activated
when it comes in contact
with a negative surface,
such as phospholipids.
So in that case, factor
XII is activated, and that
in turn will, with the help
of high molecular weight
kininogen, cleave XI to
active XI. and activated
11 will cleave 9 to 9a so
we see that in two places
now thrombin amplification
occurs because a small
amount of thrombin is
generated from that initial
tissue factor activation
and that is going to amplify
this whole generate thrombin
generation process and
thrombin as you can see
on this chart is important
for activating other things
2a is thraman and that
will activate 5 and it
will activate 8 and here we
see it up at the top involved
with activating factor
11 so we get this whole
big process happening so 9
9 plus activated 9 plus
activated 8 plus calcium plus
and that complex together
with the phospholipid
which has a negative charge
forms intrinsic 10 a's
and so 10 a's conversion
of factor 10 to factor 10A.
10A activates 8,
and thrombin activates
8, and so we get this
progressively increasing
8 activation as 10
and thrombin are formed,
and then the intrinsic
pathway converges on
the common pathway.
So 10A plus 5A as a cofactor
plus the phospholipid
will convert prosthrombin
to prothrombin,
which is important for
converting to thrombin.
Thrombin then converts
fibrinogen to fibrin.
That's it.
I recommend that you
draw it out yourself
until you get comfortable
with the process.
now there are natural
anticoagulation mechanisms
because we don't want to
be clotting all the time it
needs to be prevented and
it needs to be stopped at
the just right point so
regulators include tissue
factor pathway inhibitor
that makes sense antithrombin
which is important
because we're going to be
talking about several drugs
that increase antithrombin's
ability to inhibit these
coagulation proteases.
And I've indicated here,
this is what's in the figure.
Thrombomodulin is a
high affinity thrombin
receptor on the
endothelial cell membrane.
And you can see
that it complexes
with thrombin and
inactivates it.
And then we have
protein C, which is
a hepatic
anticoagulation factor,
and protein S, which
is its cofactor.
And nitric oxide and
prostacyclin are synthesized
by endothelial cells.
They induce vasodilation
inhibit platelet activation
and therefore aggregation
and finally fibrinolysis
endothelial cells
secrete tissue plasminogen
activator TPA and that
is actually in a drug
form TPA binds to fibrin
can't tell it here but
it's bound to the fibrin.
And that will induce
the conversion of
plasminogen to plasmin. And
then plasmin will cleave
the fibrin, and that
will reduce the clot.
We have some inhibitors
here, regulators of
this action PAI one and
two plasma plasminogen
activator inhibitor
and antiplasmin which
inactivates plasmin so
that brings us now to our
actual pharmacology we'll
begin with our heparin
unfractionated heparin,
low molecular weight,
fondaparinux, which has a
related mechanism of action,
the direct acting
factor Xa inhibitors,
and the direct
thrombin inhibitors.
Looking now at heparin,
widely, widely used, very
important to understand
what's going on with heparin,
how it works, what its
adverse effects are. so it's
this linear chain uh it's
um polysaccharides it's
in a heterogeneous mixture
in other words those
chains are of different
molecular weights you can see
the quiet wide variation
3 000 to 30 000 daltons so
the average is 15 000 but
we need to remember that
it's quite a variety in
there they're sulfated highly
sulfated so you can see
negative charge on there
And in order to be
effective, the heparin chain
must be the right length
when it binds to the
antithrombin. And I'll get
into more detail on that.
Now, heparin also, this
sticky molecule, can bind
to lots of other different
proteins, endothelial
cell surfaces, plasma
proteins, etc. And when
that happens, heparin is
not going to reach its
target of antithramin.
Therefore, it's not going
to be effective. Its action
has been neutralized.
beginning with the
pharmacokinetics IV
infusion is by far
the most frequent
route of administration
onset is very quick
subcutaneous is erratic
which makes sense
because we're heparin
just has an affinity for
binding to whatever it
happens to be around
and so the onset is in
about 20 to 30 minutes.
Sub-Q is used only
for prophylaxis
of things like deep
vein thrombosis.
Why do we need to know
the onset? Because if a
person is at risk for
producing thrombi, we need
to know how quickly the
drug is going to get
in there and produce its
anticoagulant effect.
So we mentioned
nonspecific binding
to endothelial cells,
plasma proteins.
It's polar. It has a
large size, so it's not
going to cross physiologic
membranes. It's not
going to be ******
absorbed. It will not cross
the blood-brain barrier.
It does not cross
the placenta. It does
not enter breast milk.
What is this saying to you?
you must be thinking
oh i wonder if a
pregnant person can
get this and yes
heparin is the preferred
anticoagulation drug for the
pregnant patient and the
nursing mother can also take
it non-renal elimination
it's eliminated by the
reticuloendothelial
system so that would be
the monocyte lineage
like macrophages mainly in
the liver and the spleen
it has an average half
-life of about an hour and a
half in adults children
of course have different
pharmacokinetics we must always
be aware of that when treating
children and so that half
-life is about an hour and a
half after completion of the
infusion so so maybe four
to eight hours it it's going
to be mostly eliminated
half-life is affected
by the hepatic cirrhosis
obesity malignancy presence
of pulmonary embolism
infections etc so how do
we know what's going on
well we need to monitor
the anticoagulation effect
And that's done with
the activated partial
thromboplastin time, APTT,
anti-factor 10-A assay,
the ACT,
this is the clotting time.
and platelets need to
be monitored because
of the potential
for heparin-induced
thrombocytopenia talk more
about that when we get
to the adverse effects
first the mechanism
we see on the figure
on the right hand
side a b and c
unfractionated heparin on the
top low molecular
weight heparins in the
middle and Fonda
Paranox on the bottom.
The importance of the
structure activity
relationship is that
this component here, this
sequence, needs to bind
to the antithrombin here.
So this is the
pentasaccharide sequence
so five sugar sequence and
you can see each of these
has that now the difference
between them is that heparin
is longer low molecular
weight heparin is shorter
and fondaparanox is
only that pentasaccharide
sequence fondaparanox is a
synthetic drug that was
made specifically that way.
So what's the relevance now
of this length of the heparin?
Unfractionated heparin
will bind to the
antithrombin. It will
open up the catalytic
site. It actually
increases the action
of antithrombin by
about a thousand times.
So it makes it a thousand
times more efficient so it
opens up the catalytic site
here we have our thrombin
it's in a shape that it's
going to fit in there as
you can see and the thrombin
will also bind to the
heparin so we get this
complex and this complex is
essential for heparin induced
antithrombin inhibition of
thrombin we see the low
molecular weight heparins
are too short heparin will
also inactivate factor 10
it doesn't factor 10 does
not bind to the heparin it
just binds to the antithrombin
so we see that also
with the low molecular weight
heparins and fondoparanox
so they they all will
inactivate the factor 10a
protease but But only heparin,
or a long enough molecule
of heparin, will also
inactivate thrombin. Now we
said that low molecular weight
heparins are low molecular
weights, and we're going
to talk about that more.
Some of them are a little
longer and might bind a
little bit to the heparin
and cause some, I mean sorry,
to the thrombin, but we
can't count on that. So low
molecular weight heparins
are basically factor XA in
activators through the
action of antithrombin. These
drugs have no anticoagulant
activity of their own.
Antithrombin is required.
Goal of therapy.
To reduce blood coagulability
to a level that is
low enough to prevent
thrombosis. but not so low as
to promote spontaneous
bleeding so you can see it's
a balancing act so how do
we make sure we stay in
this optimal zone by
monitoring monitoring the
anticoagulation with the
test that I mentioned before
the APTT the after the
anti-factor 10a assay ACT
so what are we using it for
well unfractionated heparin
has lots and lots of uses
it has a rapid onset of
action which makes it very
valuable especially when
we need it we need its onset
quickly deep vein thrombosis
pulmonary embolism treatment
and prevention acute
myocardial infarction unstable
angina cardiopulmonary
bypass surgery renal
dialysis the pregnant patient
adverse effects shocker
bleeding of course
bleeding getting back
to our balance point
bleeding is the
major adverse effect
of anticoagulants
antiplatelets and
fibrinolytics. I want
to put a star here.
Please remember this
neuraxial anesthesia technique
hematoma potential.
Injection into the spine
during neuraxial anesthesia,
when a patient is taking,
anything that increases
the risk of bleeding can
lead to hematoma, epidural
hematoma hematoma by
the cauda cauda equina
spinal cord and all that
pressure can cause paralysis
so it's very important
to always be aware of the
patient's anticoagulant
antiplatelet drug therapy
for lots of reasons but
particularly for these spinal
techniques heparin induced
thrombocytopenia h i
t so it comes in two
types type 1 and type 2 of
course the type 1 is benign
it occurs in a day or two
and spontaneously returns
to normal the mechanism
isn't clear it's not
really it's not associated
with thrombosis type 2
is immune mediated life
-threatening and I'll talk
about that on the next slide
long-term therapy is
associated with causing
osteoporosis now let's
talk a minute about heparin
resistance heparin resistance
is when a very high dose
of heparin is needed to
achieve that therapeutic
level of anticoagulation
as measured by APTT or ACT.
What causes it? Well,
deficient antithrombin.
That's the target.
If there isn't
enough antithrombin,
it's not going to be
inhibiting these proteases. It
can be congenital or acquired.
Elevated levels of plasma
proteins that are the
heparin is sticking to and
so it doesn't even reach
its target and elevated
acute phase proteins factor
8 and fibrinogen also
requires a greater amount of
heparin to produce the
anti-clotting effect let's
talk about the pathogenesis
of immune-mediated HIT
IgG is the autoantibody against
the heparin PF4 complex.
So let's take a look at this
figure here on the
right hand side.
IgG binds to the heparin
PF4 complex and then the IgG
will bind to the FC receptor
on the platelet, and that
will cause an activation of
the platelets, which will
release the prothrombotic
substances and PF4, because
PF4 is stored in platelets,
and this will activate
more platelets, more PF4,
releasing more activating
factors, more complexes with
heparin, activating more
platelets and on and on and
on and as you would expect the
severely hypercoagulable
state results at the same
time the reticuloendothelial
system is consuming the IgG
coated platelets and
thrombocytopenia results how do
we manage this heparin must
be discontinued immediately
and because it's a
hypercoagulable state another
anticoagulant must be started
and it cannot be heparin so
we're not using heparin or
low molecular weight heparin
a direct thrombin inhibitor
a fondaparinox or a
direct oral anticoagulant if
appropriate for the patient
the reversal agent of heparin
unfraction unfractionated
heparin is protamine
sulfate we see that it
is a positively charged
molecule that is binding
directly to heparin and
taking it out of taking
it well preventing it from
binding to antithrombin
neutralization begins
immediately the duration
of action is about two
hours the protamine
heparin complex is
cleared it's important to
dose it correctly because
too much protamine
can have an anticoagulant
effect on its own
dosing information is
available in the monograph
the heparin monograph
the protamine monograph
this takes us now to low
molecular weight heparins
and we'll also talk
about the synthetic
pentasaccharide fondaparinox
enoxaparin daltaparin
tinsaparin are the low
molecular weight heparins
i put a star on enoxaparin
it is the original
prototype of the group
and it's also widely used
star on Fonda Paranox of
course. So this is a little
figure just to compare the
actions of the different
drugs that act on, that acts
by activating antithrombin.
So we have here, this
is a representation
of our unfractionated
heparin. We
see it binding to
the pentasaccharide.
The pentasaccharide is binding
to the antithrombin site.
Heparin is also binding
with thrombin, and that
is what causes the
inactivation of thrombin.
Factor Xa can also
bind in there, but
it doesn't bind
unfractionated heparin.
Unfractionated heparin
will also inactivate
other factors, just
as antithrombin does,
but these are less important
than thrombin and Xa.
Low molecular weight heparin,
we see it binding here
to the active site, and
factor Xa is inhibited by it.
Therapeutic uses and
cautions, let's look
at the low molecular
weight heparins first.
Subcutaneous, reliable
absorption, renal excretion.
Reliable absorption.
So the effect is predictable.
It's predictable
within a given patient,
and it's predictable
between patients.
So if something is predictable,
that should suggest
that we may not need to be
monitoring it as often as
we would with something
that's unpredictable. And that
is the case with the low
molecular weight heparins.
Routine anticoagulation
monitoring is not usually
required. if clinically
indicated the anti-factor
10a assay can be used on
the Paranox subcutaneous
reliable absorption
renal excretion the same
thing the half-life of
the low molecular weight
heparins is four to five
hours maybe varies a
little bit between them on
the Paranox we see it has
a much longer half-life
for one's daily dosing.
The use is now deep vein
thrombosis, pulmonary
embolism treatment, and
prophylaxis. Same for
fondoparanox.
Low molecular weight
heparins are also used for
acute coronary syndromes,
myocardial infarction,
and non-ST elevated
myocardial infarction.
Low molecular weights are
used for warfarin bridging,
just as unfractionated
heparin is. So warfarin
bridging. So bridging, you're
familiar with this term.
Warfarin's onset of action
is several days. So once
it's started, we need to
have some anticoagulant on
board until warfarin action
takes over so that's the
bridging effect percutaneous
coronary intervention an
adjunct to it and the
cautions as for unfractionated
heparin now let's take a
look at the fondaparinox we
mentioned before that But
Fondaparinox is unlikely
to cause the immune
-mediated heparin-induced
thrombocytopenia, whereas low
molecular weight heparins can.
And Fondaparinox
is not likely to be
cross-reactive in
that state. So it can
be used for
anticoagulation for HIT.
This is based on long
experience with its use.
acute thrombosis in patients
unrelated to HIT or with
a history of HIT acute
symptomatic superficial vein
thrombosis it has an
indication for that as well
adverse effects well we're
going to expect bleeding
of course bleeding bleeding
avoid the neuraxial
anesthesia with these drugs
Low molecular weight heparins,
we have that HIT potential,
although it's less
frequent than with
unfractionated heparin, cross
-sensitivity, so we want to
avoid it in patients with HIT.
Fondiparinox should not
be used alone as the only
anticoagulant and percutaneous
coronary intervention because
it's just too short.
There are other thrombotic
processes going along so
fondiparinox is not going to
inhibit those. It can be
used with other drugs though.
So here's a brief
summary to compare them.
The unfractionated
heparin comes from a
biologic source, porcine
intestine, and low
molecular weight heparin
comes from heparin.
Fondaparinux is synthetic.
The main molecular
weight of heparin is 15
,000 Daltons, but it can
be anywhere between 3
and 30,000. Low molecular
weight average is
5,000. In general, all
of the chains are shorter
than the average
unfractionated heparin.
Pondiparinox is
small, 1,500 Daltons.
So that gives you
the idea of the
size of the
pentasaccharide component.
The unfractionated
heparin will activate
antithrombin to inhibit 10A and
2A without thrombin.
2A is thrombin.
Low molecular weight
heparin is by and
large 10A. Phonoparanox
is only 10A.
Bioavailability
subcutaneously heparin is only
30% and that's erratic low
molecular weight heparin
and fondaparinox a very
good bioavailability
half-life is variable
we see heparins is
only around an hour or
so hour or two hours
low molecular weight
is four hours and
approximately that
depends on the drug
and fondaparinox is 17 hours
that's good for
once daily dosing
Heparin is non
-renal excretion via
the reticuloendothelial system.
Low molecular weight
and heparin and
fondaparinux are renal
dosing, renal excretion.
So we need to be
remembering renal dosing.
Protamine will
completely reverse
heparin action
with a rapid onset.
Low molecular weight are
partially inactivated.
and Fondaparanox
protamine is ineffective.
Thrombocytopenia occurs
in a small number of
patients receiving heparin,
but four or five percent,
remembering that
millions and millions and
millions of people receive
unpractinated heparin,
that's a lot of patients.
Low molecular weight
heparin has less tendency
to cause the
thrombocytopenia but it's
not zero and fondaparinux
does not cause it
moving now to our direct
oral anticoagulants which of
course is turned into an
acronym which is turned into
a word doax we'll start
with the 10a inhibitors
rivaroxaban apixaban edoxaban
these are easy to remember
because we see XA band it's
banning factor 10 a stars
on rivaroxaban because it's
the original and prototype
of the group the efficacy
is very similar between
rivaroxaban and apixaban
apixaban is widely used as
well permacokinetics first
focusing on rivaroxaban
and apixaban which are
which really are the
most frequently used
of this group oral high
protein binding p glycoprotein
substrate, CYP3A45,
metabolism,
bioavailability, 50% or 60
% or 100%, but basically
it's adequate.
Renal excretion with
unchanged drug, so
we have to be thinking
about renal dosing.
The half-life of rivaroxaban
is up to nine hours longer
in the elderly patient,
and the dosing reflects it.
Apixaban, 15 hours with
the higher dose, generally
two times a day, but it
depends on the indication.
So you can see the
pharmacokinetics of rivaroxaban
and apixaban are so similar,
very similar to each
other. you remember one you
remember the most edoxaban
p-glycoprotein substrate
also but it has minimal
metabolism and it's
excreted largely unchanged
in the urine it has a
longer half-life so edoxaban
is the last one to join
this group and you can see
the pharmacokinetic profile
is different and that's
really the basic difference
with this there is some
importance with renal
function but I did not put
a star on adoxaban I'm
not going to go into it if
you see a patient on
adoxaban I highly recommend
you look it up in the drug
monograph very important
these are direct acting
so antithrombin is not
involved at all they act
directly on factor 10a
selectively and reversibly
inhibit free and clot
bound 10a by just acting
straight on it therapeutic
uses we are seeing dvt and
pe treatment and prophylaxis
that is a common thread
through all of these
they're also used for
prophylaxis thromboprophylaxis
following knee and hip surgery
atrial fibrillation but
non-valvular not mechanical
valve not bioprosthetic
because of lack of evidence
of efficacy and safety
in the clinical trials
for this group of patients
Again, routine
anticoagulation monitoring
is not required,
but if clinically
integrated, an anti
-factor 10a assay.
Bleeding. Neuraxial
anesthesia hematoma
risk. That's another
common thread.
Reversal agent. Well,
there is a specific
reversal agent for
rivaroxaban and
apixaban, and it's
called Andexanet-alpha.
it binds to and sequesters
the drugs it's actually
factor 10a and we know
that that's what these
drugs bind to but it is
an inactivated factor 10a
so it just hooks up with
the drugs and takes them
out of action there are
some problems with index
and alpha including serious
and life-threatening
arterial and venous
thromboses, ischemia, cardiac
events, and some other
problems with it as well.
But it is available
should it be needed.
Drug interactions.
CYP3A4 P-glycoprotein
inhibitors and inducers. I
don't even have to tell you
that. You already know it.
These drugs should be
avoided in combination
with the direct
acting factor Xa
inhibitors. And think
about the long, long,
long, long, long list
of CYP3A4 substrates,
inducers, and inhibitors.
P-glycoprotein, substrates,
And we often see CYP3A4 and
P-glycoprotein together.
Now the direct
thrombin inhibitors.
we'll start with the
oral one dabigatran and
it's actually a prodrug
called the etexylate
etexylate prodrug it turns
into dabigatran which is
the active and then we'll
talk about the parenterals
this little figure here is
showing you the fibrin and
we see thrombin bound to
fibrin. We see heparin here.
We see heparin here on the
antithrombin. So that's to
compare the heparin. The
direct thrombin inhibitors
bind directly to thrombin,
both clot-bound and free.
They act at the catalytic
site of thrombin. So this
figure really shows these
sites very clearly that's
kind of a stick figure
as you can see here's our
catalytic site they all
bind to the catalytic site
get in there and inhibit
thrombin thrombin also has
other sites we have a
heparin binding site and we
have a substrate binding
site and that fibrinogen
binds there and other
substrates bind there and since
they're outside the
catalytic site they're called
exocytes we see our the
bigotran which is not on this
figure because it was made
before the bigotran was
manufactured the bigotran and
our gatra band right there
in the catalytic site and
by Valerudin which is also
has is going you'll see
we'll have a star on it binds
to the catalytic site and
exocyte 1 the substrate
recognition site so it's
a two-way what we see here
is herodin herodin is a
protein in leach saliva it's an
anticoagulant protein it
was the first direct from
an inhibitor that was marketed
it's no longer available
because we have these newer
agents and a couple of
other direct thrombin
inhibitors were derived from
****** so what's going on
now if we inhibit thrombin we
prevent thrombin activity
obviously thrombin mediated
cleavage of fibrinogen to
fibrin we prevent activation
of various other factors
we prevent platelet
aggregation because thrombin
is also involved in platelet
aggregation the bigotran
and our gatrapan reversibly
and specifically bind to
the catalytic site to review
by Valarudin reversibly and
specifically binds to the
two sites the catalytic and
exocyte one I put all of
the bigotran information
here on this one slide
pharmacokinetics etexylate
oral prodrug rapidly converted
to the active dabigatran
which I put that right here
moderate protein binding
here's our p-glycoprotein
substrate again the
etexylate is converted
to dabigatran which is
active and dabigatran is
converted to some active
metabolites look at
this bioavailability only
three to seven percent
the drug developer has
done the studies and has
figured out the dose
that is going to produce
therapeutic concentrations
renal excretion what are
we thinking there and a
pretty decent half life
reversible selective
inhibition of
catalytic site of
free and clot-bound
thrombin. What are
we using it for?
I'm sure the first thing
you said was DVT and
PE prevention and treatment,
the common thread.
Atrial fibrillation
non-valvular as we saw
with the direct factor
10A inhibitor DOAX.
It is contraindicated in
individuals with mechanical
heart valves because in
clinical trials on this group
of patients it showed
reduced efficacy compared to
the comparator and excess
incidence of major bleeds.
It's also not recommended for
patients with a
bioprosthetic valve.
Monitoring, well, routine
monitoring, again,
is not needed because
the blood levels
are predictable, the
effect is predictable.
However,
activated partial
thromboplastin
time can be used if needed.
Dabigatran does have
a specific reversal
agent. It's called
idarucizumab, and it binds
directly and specifically
to dabigatran
and also its active
glucuronide metabolites.
Bleeding, of course,
neuraxial anesthesia, hematoma
risk, of course. and
it's recommended well
actually p-glycoprotein
inducers are absolutely
contraindicated and p-glycoprotein
inhibitors the therapy
must be monitored it'd
be better to avoid them
use in pregnancy not
recommended because
the data is limited
and patients who are
75 years or older should
be used with extreme
caution because of
this bleeding risk.
Patients with morbid
obesity again we should
use an alternative
because of dosing issues.
Okay our Gatriban and
bivalirudin now these are
parenterals IV IV our
Gatriban we mentioned is
a direct, it binds to
the catalytic site, the
bivalirudin binds to the
catalytic and exocyte 1.
Our Gatroban comes
from arginine,
bivalirudin is a
synthetic peptide.
So IV immediate onset,
IV immediate onset.
Our Gatroban binds to
various plasma proteins,
bivalirudin the only protein
it binds to is thrombin.
Our Gatroban has a little
bit of hepatic metabolism,
excretion of unchanged
drugs in the feces.
Bivalirudin goes out
by the urine with a
little bit of
unchanged drug, mostly
proteolytic cleavage
because it's a peptide.
Our Gatroban is used
anticoagulation in patients
with HIT so is bivalirudin
they're both used as an
adjunct and percutaneous
coronary intervention and
bivalirudin also has an
extra use as an alternative
to heparin in patients
undergoing cardiac surgery
cardiopulmonary surgery
anticoagulant monitoring
the same as for heparin
but not factor 10 a
assay and the usual adverse
effects that we're used
to seeing by now and there's
nothing else I really
want to point out
hypersensitivity is something
we always want to be
thinking about including with
these drugs and that
brings us to warfarin
Warfarin, the other coumarins,
are also known as VKOR1C
antagonists or vitamin K
antagonists. I have some
structures on the right
hand side here. You can see
the vitamin K and you can
see coumarin underneath it.
so that's your
structure activity
relationship they're
similar in structure to
vitamin K hence
vitamin K antagonists
warfarin is the one
with the box around it
warfarin comes as a
racemic mixture of the
S and the R isomers So
S-swarfarin, R-warfarin.
S-swarfarin is three
to five times more
potent as an inhibitor
of this enzyme, VKOR1C,
or vitamin K epoxide
reductase type 1C.
They differ in their
metabolism, elimination, and
interactions with other
drugs, with the S-enantiomer
being the most important. It's
the active one, and anything
that reduces or increases
blood levels of S-warfarin
can increase the risk of
bleeding or increase the
risk of thrombosis, depending
on which way it goes.
Vitamin K is a cofactor
of the gamma glutamyl
carboxylase, which is involved
in the enzymatic conversion
of prozymogens. These
are the pre-coagulation
factors to functional
zymogens, which are the
coagulation factors that
circulate in the bloodstream.
And while circulating,
that makes them available
for activation when
they are triggered.
The coagulation factors of
the liver, the vitamin K
-dependent coagulation factors
are 2, which is thrombin,
7, 9, and 10. 2, 7,
9, and 10. Some people
remember it with, my pen's
not working too well,
1972.
Maybe that'll help you.
vitamin k is oxidized in
this process vitamin k is
the cofactor for gamma
glutamyl carboxylase and
so we need the reduced
form of vitamin k as the
cofactor and it gets
oxidized in the process it's
called vitamin k epoxide
at that point and then it
has to go around the circle
and become reduced again
so we'll see that when
we look at the mechanism
pharmacokinetics the
pharmacokinetics of
warfarin are really really
important pharmacokinetics
are always important
but this warfarin has
such a high potential
for drug interactions
and much of it is related
to its pharmacokinetics
So it is oral,
rapid complete
absorption. It has been
formed. It has been
available in IV, but it's
not available in the
U.S.'s IV any longer.
And how do we dose
it? Well, first we
have to see the
anticoagulation effect,
and then we dose it
accordingly. And the
test that is used is
something called PTINR.
I'll talk about
that in a minute.
the onset of anticoagulation
is just 24 to 72 hours
but it's really longer and
I'll talk about why that
is at the bottom of this
slide the full therapeutic
effect is five to seven
days so here this explains
bridging this is why we
need bridging with heparin
or a DOAC, something that's
on board immediately.
Duration of action
of warfarin is two to
five days. That's going
to be patient specific.
Warfarin is usually taken
once a day in the beginning,
usually once a day, but
the actual dose and the
dosing schedule will be
related to the PT-INR results.
You can see the
warfarin is highly
bound to plasma
protein. It crosses the
placenta. What are
we thinking here?
No pregnancy.
S-warfarin is metabolized
mainly by CYP2C9. Please
remember CYP2C9 because
anything that affects
the function of CYP2C9 is
going to affect the blood
levels of the active S
-warfarin. our warfarin
is mainly 3a4 and an
inactive metabolites result
metabolites go out
through the urine
half-life is 20 to
60 hours it depends
monitoring pt so that's
protharaman time and
inr is the international
normalized ratio so
So the PT is going to
depend on whatever reagent
is used in the lab, and the
International Normalized
Ratio is a calculation
based on the reagent that's
used that will actually
allow standardization
of the result so that it
can be compared from one
time to the next and from
one patient to the next.
So you'll hear about PT-INR
therapeutic range of 2 to 3,
sometimes 2.5 to 3.5
for a mechanical valve.
So that's the PT-INR.
That's what that means. So
we have a high potential
for drug-drug interactions,
high potential for
drug-food interactions.
These are the vitamin K
-containing foods because
these are vitamin K-dependent
coagulation factors.
Now here's the explanation for
why the onset is so delayed.
The coagulation
factors, the vitamin K
-dependent coagulation
factors, again,
are 2, 7, 9, and 10.
protein C and protein s
are vitamin K dependent
anticoagulation factors
factor seven has a half-life
of about six hours so
it's pretty much gone in
a day factor nine has a
half-life of 24 hours so
it takes about four days
or so for that effect to
decrease factor 10 it's
about a day and a half
half-life day and a half
so that's six days and
here we have our thrombin
it's got a half-life of
about two days so this is
the reason for the delay
in onset in full effect.
So two days times four
is eight days. So factor
two, thrombin, decreases
in about eight days. Factor
ten decreases in about
six days. Factor nine in
about four days. And factor
seven in about one day.
So that explains the delay.
Protein C has a half-life
of about eight hours,
so it degrades pretty
quickly. Protein S,
which is the cofactor,
has a longer half-life.
Protein S, though, requires
protein C in order
to do its job.
So, just to reiterate,
Because of the long half
-life of some of the
coagulation factors,
especially thrombin, the
full antithrombotic effect
of warfarin is not
achieved for several days.
The prothrombin time may
be prolonged soon after
administration due to
the more rapid reduction
of these factors that
have shorter half-lives.
Now the mechanism.
Let's take a look at the
figure on the right-hand
side. Here is our vitamin
K reductase, VKORC1.
So let's go through the
process from here. We have
our reduced vitamin K.
It's a cofactor for gamma
glutamyl carboxylase. And
this enzyme is responsible
for turning the prozymogens
into the zymogens.
And this is called functional
zymogens, not because
they're activated, but
because they go into the
bloodstream and they're
circulating and available
when coagulation is needed
when they're activated.
In the process, vitamin K is
oxidized, so that's
vitamin K epoxide.
So it needs to be converted
back to the reduced
form, and that's what
vitamin K reductase does.
So,
our drugs,
S-warfarin especially,
this is the one that
has the major activity,
blocks this step.
So, we get decreased
vitamin K reductase,
and the substrate behind it is
oxidized vitamin K,
which is not active.
Here we see our CYP2C9 to
an inactive metabolite,
and other CYPs for
the R-warfarin, but
again, the R-warfarin
has very little activity.
So if we inhibit 2C9,
we can get increased
levels of warfarin, and
that can cause bleeding.
if we increase 2c9
by induction that's
going to decrease
warfarin levels
and that can cause
clot formation the
protein c and protein
s we're going to
get back to when we
come to an adverse
effect coming back though
to pharmacogenomics this is
the first and only thought
not the only the first
time that I'll be talking
about the pharmacogenetic
variabilities among these
two groups of three groups of
presented in this lecture
so if we have CYP2C9 poor
responders we're going
to get increased warfarin
sensitivity CYP2C9 reduced
functional alleles decrease
the rate of metabolism
increase the risk of bleeding
and people who carry at
least one copy of that gene.
BKORC1 genetic variants,
variation can significantly
alter the warfarin
pharmacodynamic effects leading
to warfarin resistance
or warfarin sensitivity.
Depending on whether
BKORC1 is present in
higher numbers and therefore
will cause a greater
conversion to the
reduced form, or if it's
in reduced numbers,
it will cause reduced
conversion to the active,
reduced vitamin K.
So what do we do with this
information? When determining
the initial dose, other
patient-related factors
must be taken into account,
body weight, concomitant,
medications comorbidities so
what are we going to do PT
INR we're going to monitor
and then we can adjust
accordingly got many
many uses for a long time
warfarin was the only oral
anticoagulant available it
was basically heparin and
warfarin thromboembolic
disorders prosthetic heart
valves so we get atrial
fibrillation with natural
heart valves atrial
fibrillation with mechanical
heart valves with bioprosthetic
heart valves so if a
person has a mechanical
heart valve warfarin is
the drug it's an adjunct
to myocardial infarction
uh treatment ****** acute
venous thromboembolism bridging
with with unfractionated
heparin low molecular
weight heparin ordoac
oops excuse me we
talked about the ptinr
prothrombin time and the
international normalization
normalized ratio.
Now, adverse effects.
Well, bleeding, obviously.
This occurs with higher
INRs, which brings me
to the point that
increasing warfarin dose
to higher INRs does not
increase the therapeutic
effect but it does
increase the risk of
bleeding low levels of
protein c or protein s
can remember first of all let
me back up remember protein
c has a pretty short half
-life so when warfarin is
given it inhibits the synthesis
of all of these factors
including protein c and
protein s protein c levels go
down quickly they go down
before 10a before thrombin
so and remember
that protein c is
a natural
anticoagulation factor so
we're reducing that
anticoagulation factor while
we still have the
thrombogenic factors there
so starting orphan
therapy in patients who
already have acute thrombosis
without concomitant
heparin, or other immediate
acting anticoagulant,
can increase the
risk of thrombosis,
which can increase the
risk of skin necrosis.
And of course, patients
who already have
a deficiency are at
increased risk. Now
there's something called
purple toe syndrome.
Sometimes it's called
blue toe syndrome.
And this is because
of cholesterol
microembolization
in the tiny vessels.
why does warfarin cause this
not sure maybe it releases
atheromatous plaque emboli
and they get stuck in
these small vessels I have
a picture of this so you
can see it and warfarin
resistance and warfarin
sensitivity I referred to that
before a person who requires
more than 20 milligrams a
day is considered warfarin
resistant the usual
starting dose would be five
milligrams a day to give
you a reference range it
could be because they're
taking in too many dark green
vegetables so there's
excessive vitamin k on board it
could be because of the
variant allele of vk or c1
It could be the patient
is actually not taking
the drug, or it could
be a laboratory error.
Warfarin sensitivity occurs
when patients require
a small dose. So you
see less than 1.5 mg
per day, with 5 mg per
day being the usual dose.
And that's because of
these other pharmacogenomic
considerations that I mentioned
before, CYP2C9, BKORC1.
These patients require
the smaller dose,
obviously, and they,
of course, are at
increased risk of
bleeding with warfarin.
How do we manage warfarin
overdose? The patient is
bleeding, or not, but the
INR, let's start with the
INR being greater than the
therapeutic range, but the
patient does not have
any signs or symptoms of
bleeding. So what do you do
is start the, hold the drug,
watch the PT-INR, and
then restart it when the
INR is within range,
and it might require a
dosage adjustment, maybe
a little bit lower dose.
If the INR is at 10 or
more, and remember, 2 to
3 is the therapeutic
range for most times, and
there is no evidence
of bleeding, well, then
vitamin K can be given.
Vitamin K is going to out
-compete warfarin at BKORC1,
and then the warfarin
can be started when INR
is within range. Now,
if there's serious, life
-threatening bleeding,
get that vitamin K on board
quickly, intravenously,
and the patient needs
to have replenishment
of those factors, factors
2, 7, 9, 10, C, and
S. And this is in a blood
product called 4-PCC,
Proterombin Complex
Concentrate.
Here are the pictures.
This is the skin necrosis
on the left-hand side
in a patient after
four days of warfarin
therapy, believed to be
because of the drop in
the protein C, while the
longer half-life factors
are still functional.
And here's purple toe
syndrome, also called
blue toe syndrome, with
cholesterol ambly. And
now that may be painless
or it may be painful.
pregnancy no no no no no
no warfarin in pregnancy
we see on the right hand
side you can see in the
ultrasound and in the
baby the nasal hypoplasia
also stippling of vertebral
and femoral epiphyses
hemorrhage to fetal structures
can occur cns abnormalities
spontaneous abortion
fetal death so you can see
absolutely no warfarin during
pregnancy contraindications
you can anticipate there
are going to be quite
a few active bleeding
hemorrhage temp tendency heparin
induced thrombocytopenia
because it's slow to act.
Severe, uncontrolled, or
malignant hypertension.
Bacterial endocarditis
because these patients
are already at risk for
bleeding complications.
Dissecting aortic aneurysm.
Pericarditis. Pericardial
effusion. Lumbar block
anesthesia. This is the
neuraxial anesthesia again.
so the risk of hematoma this
is true with all of these
drugs that can put a patient
at risk for bleeding
pregnancy hypersensitivity
of course drug interactions
I think that we went
through that pretty thoroughly
by now so in summary this
is just a little concept map
I made of the anticoagulants
we see They are indirect
thrombin inhibitors,
which would be
heparins, fondaparinox.
Direct thrombin
inhibitors, our 10A
inhibitors. Oh, no,
what am I saying?
Our dabigatran
and the parenteral
ones, our Gatriban
by Valorubin.
Our vitamin K epoxide
reductase inhibitors,
warfarin in other
words. and direct-10A
inhibitors, such as
riboroxaban and others.
Vitrixaban is no longer
with us. It was removed
from the market, probably
for lack of sales.
On this slide, I just put
the oral anticoagulants.
The parenterals are
pretty straightforward.
So you can compare
warfarin, riboroxaban, and
dabigatran. And you see,
Warfarin and Rivaroxaban,
good bioavailability,
Dvigatran, terrible
bioavailability, but it is
dosed to make therapeutic
levels. The Atexylate
is the pro-drug, the CYP
metabolism here, CYP2C9
being the major player there,
CYP3A4 here.
Interestingly, 2J2,
excuse me, I pushed
the wrong button and
my screen disappeared.
So we see our CYP3A4 and p
-glycoprotein with rivaroxaban.
The inducers and
inhibitors should
be avoided if at all possible.
Inducers are going to reduce
the levels of rivaroxaban
and apixaban and that
can put the patient at
risk for thrombosis.
Inhibitors can put the patient
at risk for bleeding,
ditto with P-glycoprotein.
Dibigatran, P-glycoprotein,
and P-glycoprotein,
P-glycoprotein, I'm
struggling with my PowerPoint
here, P-glycoprotein
inducers are contraindicated
with Dibigatran, and
inhibitors should be used only
with caution. You can see
the relative half-lives here
renal excretion all of
them warfarin however is
mainly metabolites rivaroxaban
and dabigatran we can
find unchanged drug in the
urine the reversal agent
vitamin K for the vitamin
K antagonists rivaroxaban
it was none it's now and
Dexanet which is may be
used or may not be used
because it has its own
problems the bigotran we
actually do have idiracizumab
therapeutic uses they're all
here and drug interactions
and that concludes the
video on the anticoagulants.